DESMOND BANE BENT OVER,
UNDERSTANDABLY SO.
AND ADAMS NEARLY BANKED IN THE
SECOND, AND SEVEN POINT GAME,
AND EVERY TIME, AS RICHARD SAID,
GOLDEN STATE GETS THE THRESHOLD,
MEMPHIS RESPONDS, AND DO THEY
HAVE ONE MORE RESPONSE WITHOUT
THEIR STAR JA MORANT.
AND NOW, WIGGINS WITH ANOTHER
ONE, AND 19th REBOUND BY KEVON
LOONEY.
>> Richard: HE IS COMING OVER TO
HELP OUT ON THE DRIVE, AND
DRAYMOND GREEN GETTING THE
TIP-IN TO CLEAN IT UP.
>> Ryan: AND JONES FINALLY
GETTING ONE TO DROP, AS HE HAD
BEEN 1 FOR 10.
GOLDEN STATE HAS 21 OFFENSIVE
REBOUNDS TONIGHT.
>> Richard: HOW MANY LAST GAME?
>> Ryan: FOUR.
CURRY WITH A DEEP ONE.
DEUCE!
THE CROWD CAN SENSE IT, THE
FIRST DOUBLE-DIGIT LEAD FOR
EITHER TEAM.
JONES, NO, AND LOOSE BALL,
CURRY.
>> Richard: AND HAVE WE NOT
KNOWN THE DIFFERENCE AND HAVE WE
NOT SEEN A DIFFERENCE IN THE
OFFENSE IN THE LAST 7:00?
>> Ryan: WAY MORE UNDER CONTROL.
>> Richard: AND GETTING ALL OF
THE SHOTS, AND NOT JUST THREES,
BUT UNCONTESTED SHOT, AND THE
LAY-UPS AND ANYTHING THAT YOU
WANT.
>> Ryan: CURRY.
NOT THAT TIME.
AND LOONEY, WHAT A BATTLE, AND
ANOTHER OFFENSIVE REBOUND.
CURRY TRYING TO GET IT TO
THOMPSON, AND LOONEY NEEDS HELP.
FINDS GREEN, AND CURRY HAS TO
PULL, BUT HE CAN'T HIT, AND
LOONEY WITH ANOTHER BOARD.
HE HAS 20, AND THOMPSON PUTS IT
IN, AND THAT MIGHT BE THE
DAGGER.